Wow
this is much much younger he asked me to
get out and and stand on one leg because
he assumed was something that wasn't
true I told him that I couldn't do that
because of a football injury and I never
played football so I bought it by a
police officer oh I can't find guilty in
college we had these girls that live
next door to us and we would do pranks
and then we would hang smelt outside
their door and then we would take it's
like a big sardine so they got back to
us by sending us this beautiful pan of
brownies but then my other roommate ate
a whole row and he was in the bathroom
for ten days because they had filled the
brownies with a speck slacks so we that
was their retribution
garbage that's for garbage man speak are
people that would put X lakhs of
brownies maybe that much I've blotted
out my childhood guilty yeah
and that was enough you haven't got a
sense
we have John Daly John Daly yeah
piercing blue eyes yeah oh these people
were going oh actually no I did show up
to a photo shoot once and it was there
was a picture of it was another actress
and with my name under it
that does mean binge Netflix no that's
where you take Jo while you're watching
Netflix whoa I've been married too long
to that side that's why it's in Norway I
married